if you've been waiting for the next big
ps4 update you'll have a chance to try
the newest improvements soon I'm Tony
and this GameSpot news update is open
for registration just a few months after
the consoles big 5.0 update sony has
teased the next quote major firmware
patch there's no word on just what this
will include or even if it's a full 6.0
version but signups are open from now
through the start of the beta itself
which is expected to kick off in
February you can sign up through the
North American or European PlayStation
sites and of course you'll need a ps4
master PSN account and be at least 18
years old to participate signing up
doesn't guarantee you'll get beta access
but you can also opt into future betas
when entering doing so in North America
will net you an exclusive avatar for now
we'll have to wait and see what the new
firmware brings the ability to change
PSN usernames has certainly been a long
requested feature and to keep up with
all the biggest firmware software and
hardware news you can always check out
our game tech Channel
[Music]
you